-Donald Trump is lashing out
at Fox boss Rupert Murdoch
amid the ongoing fallout
from a billion-dollar
defamation lawsuit
in which Murdoch admitted
that several Fox hosts lied
to their viewers
about the 2020 election.
In fact, Murdoch even confessed
that platforming those lies
was a business decision.
The court filing also revealed
that Fox and Murdoch
were secretly helping
the Trump campaign.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
For years, now,
the shtick over at Fox
has been the same.
They lie to their viewers
while simultaneously
telling those same viewers
that it's the rest of the media
who's lying to them
and that Fox is the only outlet
telling the truth.
Even now, after their lies
have been exposed
in a series of court filings,
they're still doing
that same shtick.
-They lie to you
over and over again.
How many Americans
believe these lies?
-It makes me angry
because they're lying.
They're deliberately lying.
They knew they were lying.
-I want to challenge people
watching tonight
who don't wear red hats,
don't consider themselves MAGA,
don't consider themselves
very strong political people.
I want you to ask yourself how
many times you've been lied to,
not just by this government,
but how many times you lied to
by the people whose job it is
to tell you the truth
in the media.
-Being lectured about the truth
by Kellyanne Conway is like
getting lessons on conflict
resolution from Megan.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They should start spelling
Kellyanne the same way.
[ Laughter and applause ]
But I'll count.
I'll count all the times
the government lied to me.
There was that time they claimed
the inauguration was
the biggest ever.
There was that time they said
a bunch of people died
at the Bowling Green massacre,
which is not a thing.
There was the time they said
the president didn't know
about hush money payments,
even though he wrote
the check himself.
Oh, there was that time
in March of 2020
when a government official
told us
the coronavirus
was being contained.
I can't wait to see who this is.
Maybe it's the liberal media mob
or Sleepy Joe Biden.
Oh, or that evil Dr. Fauci.
-The HHS secretary said
this morning
that we're ramping up,
we're ramping up
with the commercial labs.
-Why now? Why didn't they do it
while it was contained,
get ahead of it?
-It is being contained.
And --
Do you not think
it's being contained?
[ Laughter ]
-In addition to being
an accomplished liar,
she always talked to reporters
like a gossipy teen
at her locker.
[ As Conway ]
Do you not think Devin's going
to ask me to prom?
[ Laughter ]
Because he's definitely --
he's definitely going
to ask me to prom.
He's the star quarterback
and I'm the cheer captain.
[ Laughter ]
"Kellyanne, you're not even
on the cheerleading team."
Yeah, but I'm cheerful.
[ Laughter ]
I'm like famously cheerful.
Although,
while we're on the topic,
I'd be remiss
if I didn't mention
my personal favorite Kellyanne
lie, from April of 2020,
when she tried to blame everyone
but Trump for the COVID crisis.
-This is COVID-19,
not COVID 1, folks,
and so you would think
the people charged
with the
World Health Organization
facts and figures
-Right.
-would be on top of that.
People should know the facts.
-Yeah, people should know
the facts,
like the fact that the 19
in COVID-19 is
for the year it was discovered,
not because it's the 19th COVID,
[ Laughter ]
but good on you for thinking
they name diseases
the same way they name
Fast & Furious movies.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The coolest part in COVID-19
is when COVID convinces Spanish
flu to come out of retirement
to help break SARS
out of prison.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Anyway, the point is
their schtick is falling apart,
now that we have
definitive proof,
in these court filings from the
billion-dollar Dominion lawsuit,
that Fox hosts
were not only lying,
but they knew they were lying.
-Fox staff were privately
blasting the big lie as BS,
insane, mind blowingly nuts,
reckless.
-As Trump lawyers
Rudy Giuliani and Sidney Powell
were making wildly false claims
about rigged voting machines
after Trump lost in 2020,
private communications reveal
that pro-Trump voices
at Fox News
were calling it nuts.
-Breaking news tonight
involving Fox News
and owner Rupert Murdoch,
acknowledging, under oath,
Fox News hosts endorsed
false election fraud claims.
-Fox News boss
Rupert Murdoch said,
in a sworn deposition,
that any Fox News executives
who allowed lies about the 2020
election to be broadcast...
...or...
-Wow.
Notice he didn't say fired.
He said got rid of.
[ Laughter ]
I'd be a little nervous,
if I worked over at Fox News.
Next time you're
in Rupert's office,
make sure you're not standing
on top of any trapdoors.
[ Laughter ]
Now, just as a reminder,
I don't have
a Rupert Murdoch impression,
but I do have a borderline
offensive Australian accent,
so, I think,
if you were in your office,
it would go a little
something like this.
[ Australian accent ]
Uh, listen, Tom,
I --
[ Laughter ]
We're going to have
to get rid of ya, mate,
but we got a pretty good
severance package for you.
I'd love to fill you in on it.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Before I do, just move to the
left a little bit, alright?
[ Laughter ]
And now forward a little bit.
Yeah, that's great.
That's great and, uh, perfect.
And one last thing, Tom.
Say hi to the sharks for me,
you son of a bitch!
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thank you.
[ Cheering ]
You know it's nice
because it's --
it's like borderline offensive.
It's right on that border.
[ Laughter ]
Now, as we've discussed
this week,
Murdoch and the Fox hosts
knew they were lying
and admitted in private
they were lying,
but it wasn't just the lying.
As bad as that is,
Fox was also actively helping
and providing material aid
to the Trump campaign
during the 2020 election.
So, Fox allegedly took
confidential company information
about Biden campaign ads
and gave that information
to the Trump campaign.
That is shocking.
Also,
I can't imagine how it
could've possibly helped Trump,
since the basic gist
of Biden's campaign was,
"I'm normal and he's
out of his [bleep] mind."
[ Laughter and applause ]
I mean, what were those
strategy sessions like?
[ As Trump ]
I just heard from Rupert.
He says Biden's ads are all
about how he's normal
and I'm weird.
So, we got to start doing ads
where I look and sound normal.
Let's do some shots of me doing
normal stuff in my wheelhouse,
like drinking water,
hugging a flag,
using an umbrella,
and looking directly at the sun.
[ Laughter and applause ]
The sun. We love the sun,
don't we, folks? And we just --
we want to touch it.
We want to touch the sun.
I had a friend,
[ Laughter ]
a dear friend,
a dear friend, a Greek guy.
His name was Daedalus,
Dedalus -- either one's fine.
[ Laughter ]
Both are okay.
I never quite learned how
to say it.
He had a son, Icarus.
They made a pair of wings.
Beautiful wings.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Beautiful wings out of beeswax.
And I was there
when they took off
and Daedalus,
he said to his son, "Ic" --
That's what I called him.
I called him Ic. I said --
[ Laughter and applause ]
He said to him, he said,
"Don't fly too close
to the sun,"
but then I took him aside
and said, "If I were you,
I'd try to get
as close as you can, Izzie.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Because it looks like
a big gold coin.
It might be gold.
You never know.
You got to get
as close as you can.
And Ickie took my advice
and his wings melted.
He fell right into the sea.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Big old splash.
It was so sad.
[ Laughter ]
So -- The saddest splash.
And I remember his dad came
over to me, he said,
"Did you see what happened?"
And I just looked at him.
I said, "Hey,
it's none of my beeswax."
[ Laughter and applause ]
Also --
[ Cheering ]
Also, they gave --
they gave Trump debate strategy?
What was Rupert Murdoch's
genius debate tip,
just snort Adderall and never
stop talking for 90 minutes?
-You got to be kidding.
-Not malicious.
-Chris, he's so wrong when he
makes a statement like that.
Oh, well,
that's a big statement.
-If you let --
I support the block --
-That means you just lost
the radical left, gone.
-I supp--
-They said it would take --
No, you were number two.
China ate your lunch, Joe.
-He said, "Stupid bastards."
-Mister -- Please.
-Not true.
-He said.
[ Laughter ]
-Good debate prep, Rupert!
[ Australian accent ]
Remember, Donald, everyone
trusts a screamer!
[ Laughter ]
This is an especially
shocking revelation,
but, of course,
it's also not surprising.
There's been a long
symbiotic relationship
between Fox News
and the Republican Party
and that relationship
only intensified
during the Trump era.
On-air personalities,
like Sean Hannity
and Jeanine Pirro,
actually campaigned onstage
with Trump at a rally in 2018
and, even after Trump's
presidency was over,
Fox host Tucker Carlson was seen
cackling wildly next to Trump
[ Laughter ]
while watching a Saudi-funded
golf tournament
at one of Trump's clubs.
So, yes, Murdoch and Fox
helped the Trump campaign
and spread the lie
that the election was rigged
for political purposes,
but, as Murdoch freely admitted,
he also did it for profit.
In that same court filing,
Murdoch was asked
why Fox had continued
to give a platform
to election wingnut
and pillow guy Mike Lindell,
[ Laughter ]
who spends lots of money
on advertising on Fox,
and Murdoch said the decision
to platform Lindell
had nothing to do with politics.
It was about money.
-Today's filing also reveals,
"when asked why Fox continues
to give a platform to,"
for example, Mike Lindell --
"who continues to this day
to [lie] about Dominion --"
Murdoch said it's not red
or blue, it's green.
[ Laughter ]
-"It's not red or blue,
it's green," sounds as damning
as Colonel Jessup saying,
"You're goddamn right I"
ordered the Code Red.
[ Laughter and applause ]
When Murdoch said it,
did the lawyers in the room
make that face Tom Cruise did
when he couldn't believe
he got the confession?
[ Laughter and applause ]
The court filings
also reveal that,
despite providing aid
to the Trump campaign
and spreading his lies,
Fox and Murdoch panicked
and tried to backpedal away
from him
after the January 6th
insurrection.
-The court filing makes
clear that,
after the riot at the Capitol,
Murdoch was
through with Donald Trump,
writing in one email...
-Too late, mother[bleep].
You built this.
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's easy to put a brain
in Frankenstein when he's
a lifeless body strapped
to a table,
but good luck getting it
out of his head
while he's lumbering
around a golf course
[ Laughter ]
and interrupting weddings
at Mar-A-Lago
to give off-the-cuff toasts.
[ As Trump ]
In conclusion, love is good
and fire --
fire is bad.
[ Laughter and applause ]
To the newlyweds.
That revelation angered Trump,
who's been melting down all week
on his fake Twitter service,
trashing Murdoch and Fox News.
Trump wrote earlier this week...
"REBUKED & FORSAKEN"?
It sounds like he asked ChatGPT
to write a coked-up version
of the Old Testament.
[ Laughter and applause ]
I also do love when Trump
starts using big words,
like rebuked and forsaken,
despite the fact that he can't
spell the word stolen.
[ Laughter and applause ]
We don't know how this case
will turn out.
We do know that the filings,
once again, prove
that Fox is not a legitimate
news organization.
They actively helped
the presidential campaign.
They knowingly lied
to their viewers.
They tried to backpedal
away from Trump,
but, by then, it was too late
and now, the monster they've
created is turning on them.
If Murdoch and his allies
thought they could simply
get rid of Trump
after spending years
elevating him,
then I guess they're just...
-Stupid bastards.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-This has been "A Closer Look."
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]